[Música]
en este restaurante de buenos aires-
cada día se cocina para unas 70 personas
marcos abrió el establecimiento hace
tres años y medio por ejemplo daniel lo
que está haciendo está cortando el rock
big la mayor parte de nuestra comida es
carne entonces nuestra mayor compra
están es en la carne
como jefe de negocio tiene que controlar
los costos de sus productos sobre todo
porque en argentina desde principios de
este año los precios de los alimentos
aumentan una media de 6 por ciento cada
mes acá tenemos el ojo de bife
porcionado por este pedazo estamos
pagando cerca de 2 mil pesos hace un mes
no estábamos pagando
y 700
para no perder dinero marcos tiene que
cambiar regularmente los precios de su
menú lo que intentamos hacer es
semanalmente actualizar muy poco
nuestros precios como para no correr tan
atrás tratar de estar lo mejor parado
posible entre nuestras compras nuestra
venta y nuestra ganancia como esos se
reflejan en clientes así mismo debe
aumentar los salarios de sus empleados
cada tres meses argentina tiene una de
las tasas de inflación más altas del
mundo y en 2022 este índice podría
superar el 70 por ciento tener un empleo
en estas circunstancias ya no garantiza
escapar de la pobreza
[Música]
marilú empleada en una cooperativa tiene
que acudir a un comedor social cinco
veces por semana para alimentar a sus
dos hijas pequeñas
la comida no se puede con lo solo que
estamos recibiendo y la inflación va
subiendo todos los días y no es un solo
2% sino bastante por ciento y el sueldo
no nos sube entonces hay un problema
como esta madre soltera unas 200
personas se benefician a diario de las
comidas preparadas en este comedor
comunitario de los suburbios del sur de
buenos aires pese a la creciente demanda
hoy es imposible alimentar a más
personas y con la inflación afecta más
porque ahora vienen más te piden y no es
que nosotros queremos dar no le queremos
dar sino que no nosotros tampoco no no
no no no alcanza para poder darles una
situación de crisis que la población
argentina conoce bien en 2001 el estado
entró en quiebra
y se declaró en situación de impago las
personas que tenían ahorros los
perdieron todos
desde entonces las manifestaciones no
han parado
y el país sigue sumido en la deuda y la
inflación
[Música]
la gente está muy cansada de no llegar a
fin de mes en la luna te está cansado de
que todo el tiempo ps deudas sobre sus
espaldas por ejemplo la deuda que
tenemos con el fondo monetario
internacional- que en el gobierno de
macri la contrajo y que hoy está firmado
el acuerdo para pagarlo y que eso
repercute en que no hay trabajo pero
aparte que no hay trabajo los alimentos
suben constantemente
para ahorrar su dinero los argentinos
que pueden permitírselo recurren a una
moneda mucho más estable el dólar de
hecho en argentina los grandes gastos
como los autos o los bienes raíces sólo
se hacen en esta moneda pero desde hace
varios años está prohibido comprar más
de 200 dólares al mes así que
desarrollaron técnicas paralelas
la gente qué
que se resguarda siempre en moneda
extranjera viene acá y cambia su plata
como lo puede comprar más de 200 dólares
un mes
tiene que comprar de otra forma este
propietario de una oficina de cambio no
oficial escondida en la parte trasera de
una joyería nos responde sin revelar su
identidad porque su actividad está
prohibida de hecho todos saben que
existe
y no lo pueden frenar personas incluso
el rango alto del gobierno compra y
vende sus dólares en este tipo de
lugares
otros argentinos prefieren recurrir a
una alternativa legal sin restricciones
y que es mucho más popular en el país
las cripto monedas cada mes este grupo
de aficionados del bitcoin se reúnen
para hablar de las últimas tendencias a
jerónimo no se le ocurre una forma mejor
de ahorrar dinero
estamos acostumbrado los argentinos a no
confiar en los bancos porque nos han
dado nuestros ahorros varias veces me he
visto en los controles hoy yo tengo
amigos mi llave privada y nadie puede
ser capaz de confiscar mi llave privada
aunque las cripto monedas son muy
volátiles el valor de algunas se
desplomó en los últimos meses para estos
usuarios siguen siendo más fiables que
los pesos argentinos en la matemática
hay un software escrito con ciertas
reglas que no se van a poder cambiar el
cambio con las monedas es crucial esa
moneda fría hay que confiar en un
político y los políticos siempre cambian
las reglas sobre todo en países como
esto ahora las reglas cambian cada 10
minutos
esta noche el grupo podrá pagar su
factura en bitcoin según un estudio
argentina es el sexto país del mundo
donde más se utilizan las monedas
virtuales